can you at a high level say
what are the basic uh mechanisms of
evolutionary computation
algorithms that use something that
could be called an evolutionary approach
like how does it work uh
what are the connections to the it's
what are the echoes of the connection to
is biological
a lot of these algorithms really do take
motivation from biology but they are
carry catches you try to essentialize it
and take the elements that
you believe matter so in evolution
computation
it is the creation of variation and then
the selection
upon that so the creation of variation
you have to have some mechanism that
allow you to create new individuals that
are very different from
what you already have that's the
creativity part and then you have to
have some way of measuring how well they
are doing
uh and using the uh that measure to
select
uh who goes to the next generation and
you continue so first you
also have to you have to have some kind
of digital representation of an
individual
that can be then modified so i guess
humans i mean
biological systems have dna and all
those kinds of things and so you have to
have similar kind of encodings
in a computer program yes and that is a
big question how do you encode
these individuals so there's a genotype
which is that encoding and then
a decoding mechanism just gives you the
phenotype which is the actual individual
that then
performs the task and in an environment
um can be evaluated how good it is
so even that mapping is a big question
and how do you do it
but typically the representations are
either they are strings of numbers or
they are some kind of trees those are
something we know very well in computer
science and we try to do that but they
and you know dna in some sense is also a
sequence
um and it's a string um
so it's not that far from it but dna
also has many other aspects
that we don't take into account
necessarily like this folding and
um and interactions that are other than
just
the sequence itself and lots of that is
not yet captured and we don't know
whether they are
really crucial um evolution biological
evolution has produced
wonderful things but if you look at them
it's not necessarily the case that every
piece is irreplaceable
and essential there's a lot of baggage
because you have to construct it and it
has to go through various stages and we
still have
appendicitis appendix and we have
tailbones and things like that that are
not really that useful
if you try to explain them now it would
make no sense
very hard but if you think of us as
productive evolution you can see where
they came from they were useful at one
point perhaps and and no longer are but
they're still there
so um that process is complex
and your representation should support
it
uh and that is quite difficult
if if we are limited with strings or
trees
and then we are pretty much limited what
can be constructed
and one thing that we are still missing
in evolution computation in particular
is what we saw in biology major
transitions
so that you go from for instance single
cell to multi-cell organisms
and eventually societies there are
transitions of level of
selection and level of what a unit is
and that's something we haven't captured
in evolution computation yet
does that require a dramatic expansion
of the representation
is that what that that is most likely it
does but it's
quite we don't even understand it in
biology very well where it's coming from
so it would be really good to look at
major transitions in biology try to
characterize them a little bit more in
detail what the processes are
how how does a so like a unit a cell
is no longer evaluated alone it's
evaluated as part of a community
organism right even though it could
reproduce now it can't
alone and it has has to have its
environment so there's a
there's a push to another level at least
the selection and how do you make that
jump to this yes
how do you make the jump that's part of
the algorithm yeah yeah so we haven't
really seen that in computation
um yet and they are certainly attempts
to have
open-ended evolution things that could
add more complexity and start
selecting at a higher level but it is
still not
um quite the same as going from single
to multi to
society for instance in in biology so so
there essentially would be as opposed to
having one agent
those agent all of a sudden
spontaneously decide to
then be together and then your entire
system
would then be treating them as one agent
something like that
some kind of weird merger building but
also so you mentioned i think you
mentioned selection so basically there's
an agent
and they don't get to live on if they
don't do well so there's some kind of
measure of what doing well is and isn't
and uh does the mutation come into play
at all
in the process and what the world does
it serve yeah so
in again back to what the computational
mechanisms of evolution computation are
so
um the way to create variation
you can take multiple individuals too
usually but but you could do more
and you exchanged the part of the
representation you do some kind of
recombination
it could be crossover for instance um
in biology you do have dna strings that
that are cut and put together again
we could do something like that um and
it seems to be that in biology
crossover is really the workhorse in in
biological evolution uh in computation
we tend to rely more on mutation
uh and that is making random changes
into parts of the chromosome you can try
to be intelligent and
target certain areas of it and make the
mutations also
follow some principle like you collect
statistics of performance and
correlations
and try to make mutations you believe
are going to be helpful
that's where evolution computation has
moved in the last
20 years i mean evolution competition
has been around for 50 years but a lot
of the recent
um success comes from mutation comes
from comes from
using statistics it's like the rest of
machine learning based on statistics we
use similar tools
to guide evolutionary computation and in
that sense it has diverged
a bit from biological evolution and
that's one of the things i think
we could look at again uh
having a weaker selection more crossover
large populations
more time and maybe a different kind of
creativity would come out of it
we are very impatient in evolution
competition today we want answers right
now right quickly
and every if no somebody doesn't perform
kill it yeah
uh and biological evolution doesn't work
quite that way
uh and and it's more patient yes much
more patient
um so i guess we need to add uh some
kind of
meeting some kind of like dating
mechanisms like marriage may be in there
so to uh in into our algorithms to
improve the the
the the combination mechanism as opposed
to all mutation doing all the work
yeah and many ways of being successful
you know
usually in every competition we have one
goal you know play
this game really well and compared to
others but
in biology there are many ways of being
successful you can build niches you can
be stronger faster larger or smarter
or you know eat this or eat that or you
know so
so there are many ways to solve the same
problem of survival
and that then breeds creativity um
and um it allows more exploration and
eventually you get
solutions that are perhaps more creative
rather than trying to go from
initial population directly or more or
less directly to your
maximum fitness which you measure that's
just one metric
you